oh the Fifty Shades series has really  gone there when it comes to the sexy  scenes but there is one thing we haven't  seen as much as we see a view in these  films there's a movement to see even  more you know the fit met you managed to  make it through all three without you  know kind of going there what was what's  your reaction to them to everybody  asking for even more of you I don't know  like what to say about that  apparently we could have seen all of  Jamie though they were actually sees  that we shot where it was it just didn't  make the final cut but not that reason  but for dramatic reasons if I don't  think it adds anything or it's it if I  don't deem it to be necessary to sort of  move the story along then you know I  don't think you need to see you know  that part of me or that part of Dakota  really you know just become sort of  gratuitous if if we don't need it  [Music]